[Music]  Selena Gomez is taking time for herself  amid Justin Bieber breakup rumors a  source tells Ichi the 25 year old singer  is very delicate and is overwhelmed with  the recent media attention surrounding  her rekindled romance with Justin as  well as her family troubles the source  reveals her comeback to the spotlight  has been tough especially with the  interest in her personal life with  Justin and her mother she is taking time  to herself this is not the first time  she has done this enjoying my life et  previously reported Selena's friends and  family particularly her mother Mandy  were struggling with the couple's  reunion back in January which in turn  put a strain on their mother-daughter  relationship  [Music]  though selena and Justin are still an  item the source tells ETS Elle wants to  quote repair her relationship with her  mother that's a priority for her she  needs to figure out how to live the life  she wants in the spotlight if that's  even possible  [Music]